le plastique ce n'est pas écologique
savais-tu que chaque année nous
produisons plus de 400 millions de
tonnes de plastique nous utilisons tout
ce plastique parce que c'est facile et
pas cher un produit léger souple
résistant stable adaptable à de très
nombreuses formes mais aussi durables
problème
81% des plastiques produits deviennent
des déchets au bout d'un an
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
lopex regroupe 36 sénateurs et députés
qui ont travaillé sur l'omniprésence du
plastique et la pollution qu'il provoque
tu as forcément déjà vu un morceau de
plastique de bouteille traîné par terre
c'est ce qu'on appelle un Macroplastique
comme il est visible chacun pourrait le
ramasser et le recycler mais dans de
nombreux pays les déchets ne sont pas ou
alors mal ramassées triés et recyclés
ils finissent en pollution dans la mer
ou dans d'immenses décharges en France
ce sont 900000 tonnes de plastique qui
sont ainsi enfouis chaque année cette
énorme lorsque les plastiques sont
abandonnés dans l'environnement ils se
dégradent en tout petits morceaux qui se
disperse dans l'environnement sous forme
de toutes petites fibres de films de
granulés de mousse ou de microbilles du
coup le problème est que l'on ne sait
pas qu'ils sont là les hommes ou les
animaux peuvent en avaler sans s'en
rendre compte en mangeant du poisson par
exemple
quant aux études sur les nanoplastiques
encore plus petit elle commence à peine
mais les effets de ces derniers sur la
nature et la santé pourraient être
préoccupants on retrouve la pollution
plastique partout dans la terre dans la
mer dans les eaux douces et dans l'air
cet omniprésence a des conséquences sur
la vie des hommes et sur l'économie des
pays les Nations Unies évaluent ainsi à
8 milliards d'euros la perte économique
que subit le monde de la mer à cause du
plastique pêche tourisme et transport
les substances chimiques du plastique
peuvent contaminer les êtres vivants on
estime ainsi qu'un million et demi
d'oiseaux et 14000 mammifères meurent
chaque année en avalant du
macropastiques par ailleurs 20% des
plastiques ne sont pas recyclables ce
sont ceux qu'on appelle
thermodurcissables et qui ne peuvent
qu'être jetés c'est bien pour cela qu'il
faut prendre dès maintenant des mesures
adaptées pour lutter contre les fuites
de plastique dans l'environnement en
France plusieurs lois ont été votés
depuis 2015 elle vise à éviter le gâchis
du plastique à usage unique état
Parlement collectivité territoriale
association citoyens entreprises mais
aussi scientifiques sont de plus en plus
impliqués dans la volonté de réduire les
déchets mais il y a encore des progrès à
faire les députés et les sénateurs de
lopex recommandent aussi d'éduquer et
d'impliquer les citoyens ils appellent
ainsi à réduire la production de
plastique et veulent rendre le recyclage
plus efficace car seulement 29% du
plastique a été recyclé en France en
2019 et la France est loin d'être la
plus mauvaise élève il faudrait aussi
aussi mettre en place des structures
pour la réutilisation des emballages et
trouver une vraie stratégie pour lutter
contre la pollution chimique plastique
l'OPEX souhaite aussi que la recherche
soit soutenue et que les lois qui
touchent à la production et
l'utilisation de plastique soit mieux
contrôlée et évalué une prise de
conscience du danger est urgente car la
production devrait doubler d'ici 2050
pour en savoir plus sur la pollution
plastique rends-toi sur le site internet
Sénat junior